look at this example with me it's a bit
different to the problems we just did
isn't it can we cancel anything hmm I
can't can I why not why can't I cancel
ad here yep I can't cancel bullhead okie
boy Shh this is a real question why
can't I cancel anything off the
denominator or the numerator what's
going on what's the difference here
jasmine okay gee we're thinking about
that near antigen are now and there are
any numbers you can think of these hands
down I'll ask again a second there
aren't any numbers we can think of the
divide both okay that's the problem now
we have some language for this don't we
language we learn in the last topic
Jackie there are no common factors some
of the Japanese in class 5 as though
there's no common factors between two
and three and five she stops so
therefore what should i do what should I
do yeah
okay so i'm going to multiply across
right to x 365 x 525 now can we prove it
can't we prove it just like we started
off right I start off with this diagram
I'd like you to draw one ball and let's
represent this in a diagram now I'm
going to ask you to draw another square
but it's going to be gone this time I'd
like you to divide it up into five rows
and five columns and the five rows and
phone calls they represent these
denominators here okay so let's divide
it up
okay all right fine we want to pebble
the 14-week or use purple now I want to
represent each of these fractions on
this diagram ok so that's something the
first one two fifths okay now two fifths
I can show that here by say what'd I do
that was completed if I do one column
like that that's a fifth isn't it yeah
that's a fit now follow two-fifths I'll
go like this kedah to bits good is it
now if i want three fits obvious
three-fifths of this there's okay color
are you gonna be able to tell when read
a couple apart and find out a second
then I want while i need to divide this
up in defense and then pick three of
them don't know but I've already divided
up it appears have a nine here's one for
you no that's wrong no I don't ones I
have to fix that one there let's do this
again I'll do it for the bottom actually
there you go that's that's the way I one
show there's one feel of the red can you
tell the difference here's your chance
there's one fifth of my rent there's two
fifths of the red and there's three
fifths of the red that's three fifths of
two fears and now you can see it does
match up with six one two three four
five six out of 25 which is what we got
before positive okay
so just to review when you're adding
fractions right you don't add Vadhu rate
is and the denominator just add the
numerators but when you're multiplying
you've got to go both and you can see
the proof